Your attention,
for example,
is mediated by unconscious forces and
you know that you know that perfectly
well and this is another Freud and
observation.
You know if you're sitting down to
study,
for example,
your conscious intent is to study,
but you know perfectly well that all
sorts of distraction fantasies are going
to enter the theater of your imagination
nonstop and annoyingly and there isn't
really a lot you can do about that
except maybe wait it out.
You know,
so you'll be sitting there reading and
your attention will flicker away.
You'll think about maybe you want to
watch Jane the Virgin on Netflix or
something like that,
or maybe it's time to have a peanut
butter sandwich or you should get the
dust bunnies from out from underneath
the bed or it's time to go outside and
have a cigarette or maybe it's time for
a cup of coffee or it's like all these
subsystems in you that would like
something aren't very happy just to sit
there while you read this thing that
you're actually bored by and so they pop
up and try to take control of your
perceptions and your actions nonstop.
Maybe you think,
well this is a stupid course anyways,
why do I have to read this damn paper
and what am I doing in university?
And what's the point of life?
It's like you can really.
Well,
you can really get going if you're
trying to avoid doing your homework and,
and,
and then you might think,
well,
what is it in you that's trying to
avoid?
Because after all you took the damn
course and you told yourself to sit
down.
Why don't you listen well because
you're,
you're a mess.
And that's basically why you haven't got
control over yourself at all.
And no more than I have control over
this laptop.
Okay?
So there's the memory function of,
of,
of the unconscious,
and there's the disillusion of function.
That's an interesting one.
The unconscious contains habits once
voluntary,
now automatized and dissociated elements
of the personality which may lead a
parasitic existence.
That's an interesting one.
I would relate that more to procedural
memory.
You know,
so what you've done is practiced certain
habits,
whatever they might be,
let's call them bad habits.
And you like those things to get under
control,
but you can't.
So maybe when you're speaking for
example,
you use like and you know and you say
I'm a lot and you've practiced that so
you're really good at it and you'd like
to stop it,
but you don't get to because you've
built that little machine right into
your being,
right.
It's neurologically wired and it's not
under conscious control and anything you
practice becomes that it becomes part of
you.
And that's another element of the
unconscious,
a different part.
And then there's a creative part which
is that,
well,
you know,
you're sitting around and maybe you're
trying to write something or maybe you
want to produce a piece of art or a
piece of music,
or maybe you're just laying in bed
dreaming and you have all these weird
ideas.
And especially in dreams,
it's like what were those things come
from?
And even more strange,
one of the things that's really weird
about dreams and almost impossibly weird
is that you're an observer in the dream.
It's like a dream is something that
happens to you.
Well,
you're dreaming it theoretically.
So how is it that you can be an
observer?
It's almost like you're watching a video
game or a movie,
but you're producing it that at least in
principle,
although the psychoanalyst would say,
well,
no,
not exactly.
Your ego isn't producing it.
Your unconscious as producing,
it's a different thing.
It's a different thing,
and of course young would say,
well,
it's deeper than that.
The collective unconscious might be
producing it.
It's in some sense it isn't you exactly
or it isn't the you that you think of
when you think of you,
and that's the ego from the Friday and
perspective,
the you that you identify with,
that's the ego and outside of that is
the unconscious,
the ID that's more of the place of
impulses and you could think about those
as the biological subsystems that can
derail your thinking.
Right?
And that govern things like hunger and
sex and aggression and your basic
instincts is another way of putting it
and it's a reasonable way of thinking
about it because these are subsystems
that you share with with animals.
You share them.
Certainly with mammals.
You share most of them with reptiles.
You share a lot of them with amphibians
and even going all the way down to
crustaceans.
There's commonality,
for example in the dominance hierarchy
circuits and so these are very,
very old things and the idea that you're
in control of them is,
well,
you're not exactly in control of them
and I would say the less integrated you
are,
the less you're in control of them and
the more they're in control of you and
that can get really out of hand.
You know,
you can be like with people who have
obsessive compulsive disorder,
for example,
which,
which is,
which seems to be,
I would say that dissoluted elements in
some sense of the unconscious,
the way that it's portrayed here.
Poor people with obsessive compulsive
disorder.
They can spend half their time doing
things that they can't really control
and they have very strong impulses to do
that.
And it's very hard on them to block them
in.
Nowadays.
They'll almost panic if those things are
blocked.
And then you have people with two Rett
Syndrome,
you know,
that they'll be doing all sorts of weird
dances and spouting off obscenities and,
and,
and imitating people without being able
to control it.
And,
and sometimes a little bit of anti
psychotic medication can dampen that
down.
But it's as if there are these
autonomous semi spirits inside of them
that grip control over their behavior
and make them do things.
And you know,
you find that to some degree in your own
life because maybe you've become very
attracted to someone even.
Maybe you don't want to be attracted to
the person.
And then you find yourself texting them
when you know perfectly well that you
should be going to bed and you know,
you're,
you're in a grip of something and you
can't control it.
And that's all part of the unconscious
and all part of what Freud was studying.